PROFESSOR: Now we come to a more
serious application of the fact
that the GCD is a
linear combination.
We're going to use it to
prove the prime factorization
theorem-- which we've
talked about earlier.
This is the unique prime
factorization theorem.
So let's begin by looking at a
technical property of primes,
which is familiar, but we're
going to need to prove it.
If you believe in prime
factorization, then
this Lemma-- which says
that if p divides a product,
it divides one or the other of
the components of the product--
that's an immediate consequence
of the prime factorization
theorem.
But we mustn't
prove it that way,
because we're trying to use this
to prove prime factorization.
So how can I prove, based
on the facts of what
we know about GCDs,
without appealing
to prime factorization
that if p is a prime,
and p divides a
product, then it divides
one of the components
of the product,
either the multiplier or
the [? multiplicand? ?] OK,
well here's how to prove that.
Suppose that p divides ab,
but it doesn't divide a.
Of course it does
divide a, I'm done.
So we may as well assume
that it doesn't divide a.
Now that means that since
the only divisors p are p
and 1-- the only positive
divisors of p are p and 1--
that if p doesn't divide
a, the GCD of a and p is 1.
All right, now comes the
linear combination trick.
Given that the GCD
of p and a is 1,
that means that I have a linear
combination of a and p that's
equal to 1-- sa plus tp is equal
to 1, for some coefficients, s
and t.
Cool-- multiply everything
by b on the right.
So that means that sab plus
tpb is equal to 1 times b.
But look at what we have now.
The first term on the
left is something times
ab, and p divides ab, so that
first term is divisible by p.
The second term
explicitly has a p in it,
so it's certainly
divisible by p.
So the left hand side
is a linear combination
of multiples of p,
and therefore, itself
is a multiple of p--
which means the right hand
side is a multiple of p, and
the right hand side is b.
So sure enough, p divides b.
We're done-- a very
elegant little proof
that follows immediately from
the fact that you can express
the GCD of two numbers
as a linear combination
of those numbers.
Now this is the
key technical Lemma
that we need to prove
unique factorization.
A corollary of this that
I'm actually going to need
is that if p divides a product
of more than two things--
if p divides a product
of a lot of things--
it has to divide at
least one of them.
And this you could
prove by induction,
with the base case being
that it works for m equals 2.
But it's not very
interesting, and we're
going to take that for granted.
If p divides a
product of any size,
it divides one of the
components of the product.
All right, now
we're ready to prove
what's called the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic, which
says that every integer greater
than one factors uniquely
into a weakly decreasing
sequence of primes.
Now the statement
of weakly decreasing
is a little bit
technical and unexpected.
What we want to say is
that a number factors
into the same set of primes.
Well that's not quite right,
because the set of primes
doesn't take into account how
many times each prime occurs.
You could try to make a
statement about every number
uniquely is a multiple
of a certain number
of each kind of prime.
But a slick way to
do that is simply
to say, take all the
prime factors, including
multiple occurrences of
a prime, and line them up
in weakly decreasing order.
And when you do that,
that sequence is unique.
This fundamental
theorem of arithmetic
is also called the prime
factorization theorem.
And here's what it
says when we spell it
out-- without using the
words weakly decreasing.
It says that every
integer, n, greater than 1
has a unique factorization
into primes--
mainly it can be expressed as
a product of p 1 through p k
is equal to n.
With p 1 greater
than or equal to p 2,
greater than or equal
to each successive prime
in the sequence, with
the smallest one last.
Let's do an example.
So there's a number
that was not chosen
by accident, because I worked
out what the factorization was.
And it factors into the
following weakly decreasing
sequence.
You start with the
prime 53, you followed
by three occurrences of 37,
two 11s, a 7 and three 3s.
And the point is that if you
try to express this ugly number
as a weakly decreasing
sequence of primes,
you're always going to get
exactly this sequence-- it's
the only way to do it.
All right, how are we
going to prove that?
Well, let's suppose
that it wasn't true.
Suppose that there was
some number that could be
factored in two different ways.
Well, by the
well-ordering principle,
there's at least one.
So we're talking about numbers
that are greater than 1,
so there's a least
number greater than 1
that can be factored
in two different ways.
Supposed that it's n.
So what I have is that n is
a product p 1 through p k.
And it's equal to
another product, q 1
through q m, where the p's
and the q's are all prime.
And these two weakly decreasing
sequences are not the same.
They differ somehow.
So we can assume that the
p's are listed in a weakly
decreasing order, and the
q's are likewise listed
in weakly decreasing order.
Now the first
observation-- suppose
that q 1 is equal to p 1.
Well that's not really possible,
because if q 1 is equal to p 1,
then I could cancel the
p 1 from both sides,
and I would get
the p 2 through p k
is equal to q 2 through q m, and
these would still be different.
Since they were different,
and I took the same thing
from their beginning, I'm left
with a smaller number that
does not have unique
factorization, contradicting
the minimality of n.
So in short, it's not
possible for q 1 to equal p 1.
So one of them
has to be greater.
We may as well assume that
q 1 is bigger than p 1.
So q 1 is bigger than p 1, and
p 1 is greater than or equal
to all the other
p's, so in fact,
q 1 is bigger than
every one of the p's.
Well that's going reach
a contradiction because
of the corollary.
What I know is
that q 1 divides n,
and n is a product of the p's.
And since q divides the product
of the p's, by the corollary,
it's got to divide one of them--
q 1 must divide p i for some i,
but that contradicts the fact
that q 1 is bigger than p i.
That's not possible
for the larger number
to divide the smaller number.
And we're done.
And we have proved the
unique factorization theorem.